hey what is up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 25 a 3d game
programming in Java this is the real
episode 25 and I just realized there's
no water around that sucks anyway let's
let's get on with it so India I guess in
the trailer
one of what you guys want to call like
the snake baked episode um I said that
will we'll do some fall stuff where we
actually because at the moment like if
we if we go do this and we set the
resolution to this right yet okay and
you hit play and it's like that right
but then we started again we hit play
and we're like oh well that's not what
we said you know do we really want to go
to options every time select the
resolution every time when we launch it
and hit play and then next time you open
the game you have to you know you have
to do the exact same thing like I don't
want to do that how can we how can we
how can we um you know change that so
the way the best way to do this is
actually to save I guess all of our all
of our options into like a file into a
configuration file now I'm most
different games handle this differently
in the real world all right it's pretty
popular to save configuration into XML
files and that's probably actually that
is what we'll do with this but there are
other ways to do it there are ini files
there are just freakin text files
honestly it files with no extension even
here's another popular choice for
configuration files and there's just
there's tons of stuff but um there's a
bit of a toss up in Java between which
ones you want to use this because there
is properties there is dot properties or
dot props and there is XML now I'm gonna
use XML for this tutorial just because
I'm I've had more experience with it a
but BAE it's it's sort of like a
standard it's not really standard but it
is popular to use XML files to to store
you know keys to store values um and my
record is using high disk usage that's
always good only two minutes alright
let's get started so at the moment yeah
let's just jump into this alright so
whenever we basically the way this is
gonna work is whenever we actually hit
OK on this um on this thing we want to
actually save this
value to a file all right every time we
hit that and then whenever we hit play
we want to load that file and get the
value and set it to that resolution that
we want that's sort of the way we
actually want to do this so I guess what
we need to do first of all is sort of
make a um like a like a file like a
class rather a class to actually process
this now I'm actually gonna put it into
the main I reckon the main package and
I'm I don't know I'll just call it
configuration you guys can call whatever
you want you had a drill configuration
then I call a config because because I'm
professional and called I'm gonna call
it configuration I hit finish so now
we've got a class obviously uh-huh and
it's actually been a wild since I've
recorded tutorials I'm not sure I'm not
sure what to say but uh we want we want
a few methods I guess the first one the
first method we actually want is a way
to actually to save basically to create
I guess a sort of file right we want to
create an XML file and we want to store
you know that the initial data to it all
right we don't want to load it we want
to yeah we want to sort of a way to
write to a file not read yet just right
so public void save I'm gonna call it
save configuration and I don't know what
we'll probably go string key and int
value so basically a key in XML is I'll
show you guys actually let's uh let's
try and go file file equals new file so
what this is going to do is suppose they
create a create a file
what's import file in the file class
this isn't going to create a car this
isn't gonna really create a file it's
just gonna create an instance of a file
at whatever the location of the file is
so at the moment if we look at the data
structure that we've actually got for
mind front we've got our resources
folder and then we go to extras folder
now I'm gonna make another folder here
when I call it configuration
configuration and then this is sort of
where I want to call that Michael like
settings or something alcohol settings
and this is sort of gonna be the config
file so let's go config dot XML and
actually make sure that you go to
settings / configuration I'll remember
that the rizal's as file as part of our
build path to Java so it'll be able to
immediately find that so build path
there it is it's a class folder alright
so once we're on that let's just write
out why I just don't like this little
syntax area let's catch what is catcher
well just cache an exception if you if
you're on exception a it's gonna catch
any exception so whatever exception it
does doesn't matter if it's like a input
out with exception if it's a Naren Dex
had a found that's everyone know any
exceptional a nullpointerexception
whatever it's gonna it's gonna catch any
exception that it gets into what I was
here but which is gonna be nothing cuz
you know don't really need to do
anything if it's spirit is screwed oh I
guess I don't really attitude to have
but um I can't be bothered actually uh
you know capturing that so um we need a
check often we've actually created that
instance when it we need to check you
know is the file there because if it's
already there we don't want to create
another one because if we if we create
another file it's gonna override that
existing file and if it does is gonna
override it obviously with new data so
that's not what we want to do we want to
check if it's there and if it's not we
want to create a new file so well create
a new boolean called exists exists and
we'll put that to file dot exists all
right and then we'll say that if it
doesn't exist if it doesn't exist
actually let's just put it to give this
not exists if it doesn't exist let's
file dot create new file so if it
doesn't exist we'll create a new file
there with this name and let's just
let's just see if that works so this is
what grades this is the code that we're
actually crazy file so at the moment
we've got completely nothing here
let's when we hit options let's go to
let's set up the object we might as well
name it later configuration config new
configuration and love to import that
make sure you import the one that's in
our class not the securityq one and
config dot save configuration and don't
worry about this again this can be
absolutely anything you want at the
moment because we haven't actually we
haven't actually um made these
parameters do anything yet in our method
hmm so let's just see if that works so
at the moment we've got nothing when we
hit options we should see a file there
hit options and you can see that we have
no file there folder them to you
interesting maybe it creates it in hmm
I'm just curious as to where it hmm test
XML let's say fit uh
all right so mmm that is interesting I
guess we should have probably created in
hang on a minute
res maybe really doesn't really mmm Oh
wood deck oh yeah wood that's actually a
good point that's I yep okay let's see
if this works well did I really close it
I keep on closing it let me try and find
the thing again mine France settings hmm
surely that should have created it huh
interesting
hmm all right well we'll deal with the
root directory for now uh I'm not sure
actually I haven't dealt with this in a
while so let's just um play around with
it yeah okay that was my bad for putting
that slash that don't put a slash there
for future reference all right so no
file here hidden settings so res
settings yep
hit the debug button hit options and you
should see a file here all right cool so
that worked yeah I'm not sure actually
my bad don't put a slash here don't know
why I did I was um I'm doing a web
development project and in that you can
put slashes there when in fact the UH
the links but apparently Java doesn't
like that so you learn something new
every day um I actually bet they didn't
actually know that it mattered okay so
when I sort of make an output stream now
there's two things we'll be using an
input stream and an output stream input
stream is sort of when we want to get
data so we want to get input we want to
read dollar basically output stream is
when we want to place you know data we
want to write data so output is right
input is read remember that output
stream
it's got write equals new file output
stream it's a file output stream and
then we actually have to find that path
so because we're sort of starting to use
this path multiple times I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna cut that and we'll make a
string we'll call it like path and we'll
just go string path equals that so that
we don't have to you know and then if
here we can just put path so even so
that we don't have to don't do it
multiple times control shift or to
import this and we're actually gonna use
something as well called the properties
class so the properties class is kind of
useful for writing properties to files
to XML files or dot properties files so
properties properties equals new
properties and make sure you import that
as well a lot of important to do in this
class okay so I think that I've
explained it so far
so what what we want to do now is
actually load data that file we want to
load we sort of wanna actually we don't
need to load that's a good point
we don't even load yet we don't just
need to set the property and so what
this does is we I guess we sort of set
the property and we want to string key
and string value that's actually that's
actually perfect except we actually have
to make that a string so let's just go
integer a dot true string and that's
gonna convert this integer called value
into a string for us now you might be
asking yourself why don't you just go a
string value because the reason I didn't
do that is when I'm dealing with
resolutions to stuff I like to keep it
as numbers when possible and then I like
to convert it out of numbers when
possible as well because um you guys
will find you guys will find that it
it's actually it's a lot more beneficial
to deal with actual numbers because if
you want to divide numbers you can do
that you can't divide strings all right
so try to keep your resolutions as
integers whenever possible as you can
see here we couldn't which is why I did
that
so yeah okay so now that we've actually
we've set that property we actually have
to write
we actually have to write that property
to an XML file so make sure you go store
so properties that store to XML don't go
store that's going to sort it to a
property file we want to sort to an XML
file so go store to XML and now we need
to use that app let's trim with we
created here called write and comment
now this is sort of like this is gonna
be like a comment so it's literally a
comment you could go knoll it's not
gonna created in comments if you're no
you don't that's perfectly acceptable
but I'm actually gonna call it
resolution so this this is sort of going
to still a property of our resolution so
the width and our height okay cool so
let's say let's try and run this code
and see what it does options ah did I
close it again come on dude Oh keep on
closing that thing as if I don't need
any more gonna not close it next time
all right so we've got our config dot
XML file and if we open that up and
notepad then you can see that we've sort
of got entry key called SD and the value
of that is one and that's because over
here I made the enter key as d in the
value one alright cool so now we've um
now you can see how that how those keys
work and resolution that's just a
comment yeah that's a comment same thing
as doing you know this in Java that's
just basically for us to know again if
we put null actually I've actually never
tried to do no I'm guessing it's just
not gonna put anything there I have
always loved comments because it is
easier right if you do leave comments
but curiosity yeah it's just it's
exactly it's just not gonna leave a
comment that so it's up to you if you
really want it I like to keep my stuff
really organized which is why I will
make a comment called resolution but um
I'm gonna change one thing actually
let's just that's kind of annoying let's
cut this card and put it into um when we
when we hit okay we want to save that
configuration and you can see that it's
not coming up with any errors because
options extend
won't jump so just in case you were
wondering why we can still do that we
are we're good we're good to go
all right cool so um yeah so we got this
now now if we hit okay it should create
that file and you can see it's got a
comment back here okay cool awesome so
what let's actually um okay so we've
created a way to sort of store of XML
now let's let's go ahead and and I guess
get a way to actually store our
resolution to that XML instead of um SD
and one so when we hit this la alright
let's make two integers let's make one
called width and one called height we
don't need to populate that with
anything at all and then we can go if
selection and we haven't made a slash in
a variable I thought we did because I
looked about
alright so instead of displayed election
we'll just go into selection equals
resolution to get selected index so
that's obviously going to get the index
of mmm maybe I'm rushing this term
mantra and I haven't done time ah I am
out of practice I literally have not
done a literal like three ways to wake
something the new channel thing has just
been driving me insane anyway this is
this is this election of X so that that
would be selection index 0 1 & 2 alright
so if this election index is is 0 so if
selection equals 0 then we need to set
with equal to 640 and hide equal to for
ready if selection equals 1 and I'm
actually going to go or selection equals
negative 1 and you might you guys might
be like what negative 1 how can you go
negative 1 and I'll explain that in a
minute
width equals 800 height equals 600 and
finally if selection equals I should be
copying and pasting this code when I'm
typing now for you guys if it's election
equals to width equals 2024 and height
equals 7 6 8 all right cool negative 1
if you go over here you can see that it
actually says this helps you out a lot
by the way
show this out alright so if nothing is
selected returns negative one so if we
don't select anything for some reason
instead of like not knowing what to do
and basically giving us the width and
height of null and causing a potential
nullpointerexception we can say that
different if if the user doesn't
actually select anything for some weird
reason somehow he manages to leech out
the system and not select anything then
set it equal to the default value which
is a Harper 600 and that is where is my
what the frick where is my thing gone do
you guys say that there it is back now
the the type ii thing he was gone we had
anyway so now we want to create we want
to save a configuration of width and
we'll put the width to W and we also
want to and W is ah look at that we do
need to initialize it in height equals
zero as well so we'll just set it to
zero closer to a tower by 600 but we'll
just set it to zero so that if if our
window ends up being this small we know
we had an error so because if we if we
see that at equal to 800 buzzing son we
might not notice what goes wrong so
that's we've we've we've ran that method
once for with now we need to do now we
need to run it again for height so yeah
let's um so check it out options okay so
it should be 800 by 600 I've closed it
again what is wrong with me today
god I can't freakin closing that folder
with um Oh weird all right here we go
we're back here so res settings config
so now you can see that we've got two
electric is one for with one for height
and one for width and is 800 by 600 if
we if we were on the code again and it's
like 640 by 480 then it should oh I'm
still running the other instance then it
should actually put 640 by 480 as you
can see and um oh we forgot to and if I
run it again I guess it's not that it
matters but thousand 24 by 768 then you
can see that uh 1024 by 768 but if I hit
play then it's not it's gonna launch it
at 640 before Eddie so actually
affect the resolution so that's the next
step but yeah because you guys are
wondering you know is it actually
overriding that file every time it's not
overriding that file every time okay
it's only creating a new file remember
it's only creating a new file if there
is not a file there okay otherwise it's
just loading that file so don't don't
forget that all right cool so I guess
what we'll do next as well
probably I'm just thinking of best way
to do this I should probably press this
tutorial more often but I just can't be
screwed yeah I reckon well okay let's
create a method before we actually set
the resolution let's create a method
from learning from an XML file so in
other words we want to save that data
now we've saved that data successfully
but we're not retrieving it in any way
you know well well entree and game
we're hitting play and then we're being
like well you know so what I don't care
what that what that data is we haven't
actually passed it P AR sed it um that's
a little spelling a tutorial for you
guys so let's create another method
public would load configuration so we
don't save now we need a lord and all we
do well what we need here is path
because it's oh my Mike okay as well
we'll see I don't know I haven't done
this before like I've done it before
we're not not in this way we'll catch
two exceptions will actually fall two
will actually catch a file not found
exception and you guys might be like you
know like catching that specific
exception and we'll also catch one more
and that will be any other exception so
well actually the only other exception
for this that could possibly exist is
input output exception sure Joseph oh
don't put both those clauses a and let's
call this one a one all right actually
we don't need to call that a one because
it on the same device expect it
packagin okay exception for all them
that's important Oh exception that how
you spell exception it should be there
we go ah okay don't worry it'll hold it
up because when I'm actually actually
catching anything new file input stream
so we've done an output stream which is
output stream because new file output
stream now we need a I'll call it read
actually I call it input I'll call it
read that's actually probably good
because we call the other one alright so
read input stream radicals new file
input stream and again path so whatever
that path is if there's a me there's
actually only one path at the moment is
analysis probably not we might have
multiple configuration files let's
import both of them finish cool we might
have multiple configuration files in the
future I don't know maybe one for actual
saving levels saving like level
locations like your your character
wherever he is in in the 3d world we
might have one for that which is why I
don't really want to put that into the
same XML file is config so that's why
I'm not that's why I'm leaving a path
here
alright so let's load this now
now this listen up carefully to this
alright not not not that there's any
part of this tutorial which you
shouldn't be avidly listening listening
to her but um listen up to this part in
particular because I was doing this a
few days ago and this literally drove me
insane because I got it wrong and it
took me about a week ok not awake three
days four days to diagnose this right
load not load load from XML big
difference you you try to load that
that's gonna return you null and when
that returns you know that means that
you're not gonna be able to find those
case because there's no file there's
there's a non-existent file with
non-existent strings with non-existent
keys
if you know what I mean so you're not
gonna be able to actually load that
particular key which now you know case
is is within height because they don't
exist and that will return you null
which means that no matter how hard you
try it's never gonna actually return the
right result so make sure you go a load
from XML saving you guys so much time
right now do that load from XML because
you're safe you're storing to XML you
need to also load from XML okay alright
again read okay so now I've sort of gone
that little thing now we need a I'll
create a string called width and that'll
actually be the key in our thing called
with the entry key called width so we
want we we want to get that now so
string with equals properties dot get
property and the width
make sure you um put that in quotation
marks obviously and same thing we need
to do for height whenever we want to
also load Heights highest all right so
we're loading both those now now what we
want to do is actually sort of we've
loaded we've we've gotten those things
let's print off with plus height let me
just um
with pickles plus height height equals
plus height so when I actually loading
it okay whenever we hit oh that she
launcher whenever we hit play we sort of
want to load that so config dots load
configuration we want to look we wanna
Lord from res slash again not flash res
just read slash or is it setting slash
config and the K we wanna Lord is yeah
I'm not gonna have a K thing then that's
stupid we want to load the entire file
not just one K yeah I mmm okay I'll do
it this way if if if in a few tutorials
or something in like ten tutorials this
turns out to be a problem I'll change it
but I don't think the world so just yeah
bear with me it should be fine so yeah
let's so whenever we hit play we're
going to load that configuration file so
whenever we hit play we should say be
with and hard to be that if we change
this to that and this to that and we hit
play then you should see it's reflected
in the console so right there okay
awesome let's let's reso it's the moment
crazy huge resolution so let's just
resave it in options so we get our
original res back cool that's actually
functioning correctly thank God
okay so what we what we want to do now
is based on those parameters we want to
set that resolution equal to something
okay so we want to actually physically
set that resolution equal something so
we've got here a the other thing called
the selection public static int
selection and based on this is gonna set
that resolution to what we want which is
perfect because it makes our life really
easy
so what we can do is say that you know
if if that if if with turns out to be
eight hundred and hi it turns out to be
six hundred let's set the selection
equal to 1 because if it's 1 then we get
our we're tickled 800 and our height
equal to 600 so that's that's really
cool so with that in mind let's create a
new method called public avoid set
option and we'll just go in width and
height so this is what like set
resolution actually set resolution so
let's just say that if width equals 600
640 roller and again we don't need a we
don't need to deal with strings here
because we're using integers so yeah
awesome
if with equals eight 640 and height is
equal to 480 because if they're not
actually in 4/3 we have we actually if
you haven't noticed we haven't actually
made our game widescreen here or
anything it's only stock at that aspect
ratio if we stretch it out then it's
gonna look bad because it doesn't
actually just it doesn't physically let
us say great area it just stretches that
out horizontally not good so um we only
want to deal with 4 3 at the moment so
if with is 640 and height is 480 then
let's set display tough selection to 0 I
believe I think zeros yeah there is a
first assumption and let's just copy and
paste that method a few times you could
probably set this equal to you know
public and set resolution and have it
return particular methods I don't want
to deal with that now they're one and
two four eight hundred and six hundred
and seven six eight and a thousand
twenty-four so self-explanatory I hope
you guys got that so now let's actually
run this method
and let's go in here and type set a
resolution now these are actually
strange at the moment with a knight so
let's convert them back into into a
integers and that's is as simple as
going integer dot parse int and we'll
pass the width and then we'll do the
same thing integer pass int and we'll
just anything behind and yes let's check
this out options 640 by 480 cool let's
run load again awesome we're aware I
can't tell if that works a lot because
that was the default thousands 24 by 7 6
8 hit OK hit play that's obviously
thousand twenty four by seven six hey
let's close
let's open again hit play and look we're
back in two thousand twenty four by
seven six eight awesome and if I go into
here and change this to like for ID and
this to like oh no make it 800 600 and
800 there on it you can see that awesome
word 800 by 600 and you can see that
right here cool so let's get rid of this
we don't need that anymore the system
thing and now we actually want to do
something and that is we've we've sort
of we're reading that file at the moment
from path we want to sort of close that
now so read dot close that's just that
actually called that actually unloads
the releases any system resources
associate associate with this dream it's
gonna sort of delete that file from the
memory now so it's not taking up any
processing power or storage or Ram so
that's important that you do that close
ok so why do I make this you might be
asking pretty simple because you'll see
that if we eat dot print distract stack
trace we go onto here and we delete this
file and we try and run this it's gonna
crash it's not gonna crash but it is
because it's not actually gonna crash
but you can see that it cannot just
freakin stop this there we go you can
see that system cannot follow find the
file specified so it defaults to 640 by
480 which is good because it doesn't
crash
it just it double does suddenly crash so
if that does happen and you can see that
we're left without a file and we don't
want to we don't want that to happen so
this is actually the first real time in
this in this mind front project where
I'm actually going to actually handle
exceptions properly so if there is no
file currently there then let's create a
file and how do we create a file we
could we call the save configuration
method so if that does happen let's uh
let's save configuration and again we'll
save with and again this is where you
can play around with this equal the
default is 800 by 600 so let's just do
that 800 by 600 for height and that's
all cool you guys me it might be like
yeah that's awesome I'm at the moment
how far does exist we hit play oh wait
hang on it so it wait wait what just
happened well first of all I close the
damn thing again kind of ruining that
where are we workspace to mine front its
settings hang on it's at 640 by 480 but
we created filed 800 by 600 how come
pretty simple I almost closed it again
we next time we launch at 30 will be 800
by 600 but it didn't do it that time why
not because this method has already been
ran and this is the method that actually
sets our resolution equal to whatever we
want so we need to run this method again
and the way we do that is we just go
load configuration it's as simple as
assume I think it is load configuration
and path so Isolators again and we
default to that thing and we do get that
file so that is actually probably the
end of this tutorial we're at 33 minutes
that's nice
it's nice not too long not too short if
you have any questions leave a comment I
think this is probably and if we get
another input-output exception just
dinner pretty this - erase whatever
that's yeah and we'll just put it in
same thing here for good measure
that's just if we're debugging him this
happens to happen then it can just print
the stock price for us so that we know
it's crashed it hasn't crashed we just
know that it hasn't worked as intended
yeah cool all right I think I think
we're good actually
all right I actually done everything I
was gonna do in the straw I think so
well it works so now we've permanently
got a way to actually save now our
configuration data to to disk you can
see that now
so yeah so I hope you enjoyed this
tutorial hit the like button if you did
let's get back to getting those life
let's try and hit 100 likes this time so
click that like button let's get a 100
likes and I have zero clue what episode
26 is gonna be about so why don't you
guys drop a comment below telling me
what you want to see episode 26 and
something reasonable at this stage in
development and yeah cuz I have no idea
oh one more thing actually this is for
the pros who decided to stay by a few of
you guys were complaining that these
buttons weren't appearing so like you'd
watch it I can't actually induce it it
does I don't know what determines it but
sometimes you'd see this without any
buttons and you'd actually have to put
your mouse over where the buttons should
be in order to actually umm to see the
buttons and that was like a weird sort
of bug and the way fix that is when we
actually launcher when we actually um do
this what we should do is just run the
repaint method and that'll actually
force them to show up so that's
something I can't show you guys I can't
show you guys them not showing up right
now but if you you know you know if
you've got if you've had that problem
and just put in a repaint just like that
but of the component class if you put
rate if you just just put in repaint
like that repaint and it should should
draw your buttons properly so yeah
anyway this that's pretty much it make
sure you follow me on twitter link is in
the description because I'm updates and
some of that I always book post updates
there and tell me what you want in
episode 26 cuz I've I have no idea and
yeah so I hope you enjoyed this episode
hit the like button and I will see you
guys now
week or maybe throughout the week
depending on what I feel like doing let
it guys by